[Musique]
dans cette ville tout
comme les autres trois amis vont à vous
[Musique]
une surprise incroyable et où il se
passe quelque chose je viens vous sur
jarnac où jacques robin regui ti l'eau
est ce que tu sais dire autre chose que
juste trio l'eau
nous honorons cette créature un esprit
protecteurs des animaux et des enfants
tu te rends compte si tu avais découvert
là dedans tu es sûr que tout va bien ici
[Musique]
bia c'est une bête très rare et me suit
il s'agit d'un getty et celle être plus
gentils et affectueux du monde non peut
te rendre invisible pour les gens 0 ces
méga cool mais ils ne sont pas les seuls
à vouloir le yéti il avait raison c'est
un yéti
il me faut cet animal je suis chasseur
je chassais personne n'a jamais échappé
à mes pièges de panthère maintenant que
leur nouvel ami se trouve en danger tout
type du zoo qui arrive faut les trouver
une cachette je veux savoir où il est
ils font tout ce qui est possible
avery pour le protéger où est-il pas
l'intention de le demander de voix
venez vivre une aventure
donc vous avez toujours rêvé
sony pictures présente
après l'extraordinaire décélère de knie
steurs l'auteur à succès de lili la
petite sorcière yoko
o globo
[Musique]